what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
so Suicide Squad going sane it's
probably the best thing coming out of DC
rebirth right now and the reason why is
because this gives us a story where
Harley Quinn goes back to being a sane
human being less she goes back to being
normal and it's actually kind of cool
because we don't really see this that
often because Harley Quinn's character
with regards to her being bonkers and
game bananas is one of those things
where it works really really well
depending on who's writing this story
and what context she's in like if Harley
Quinn were hanging out with the Justice
League it'd be hilarious to see her just
babbling nonsense and just being crazy
but when she's hanging out with a
Suicide Squad then it's kind of run for
you know it's kind of par for the course
and so again it's sort of an interesting
scenario but what this does is it comes
as a direct follow-up to the last video
that we did now if you missed that last
video all that really did was give us
this idea that the Suicide Squad which
is basically this group run by Amanda
Waller
they were basically still on a mission
to locate something called the black
vault now once they actually accessed it
they ran into a character named hack who
basically had the ability to take
physical objects and turn them into
digital information and teleport them
over any length but once they
encountered this black ball they
basically discovered that the black
vault contained General Zod now General
Zod of course is one of Superman's most
notable enemies but the issue that we
had with that is we didn't really know
how it was that he ended up there it was
just he was stuck there one day
but this follows up to directly after it
is in the black vault it's sent directly
back to back to to Bellerive prison
where the Suicide Squad operate out of
now one of the people who were killed in
the last story or at least the only
person who was killed in the last story
arc was Captain Boomerang and of course
with the Suicide Squad somebody always
dies I mean that's just normal somebody
always ends up getting killed off it's
really just a hallmark of the story at
this point but what is up happening here
is that once the black vault is brought
back to Belle Reve everybody starts
experiencing these insane phenomena
whether personalities basically reverse
and so it's very similar to Marvel's
axis just not on nearly as much of a
grandiose scale and not nearly as poorly
written but it is an interesting story
in so far that this basically gives us a
lot of the characters and inverts their
personalities and so for the most part
each individual that's highlighted in
this story is designed to be shown in a
way did they basically face their own
demons and they struggle with their own
issues now somebody else did I want to
point out here is a character by the
name of
Harcourt now amilia hardcore dizzily
Azon between the NSA and the Suicide
Squad and that's one of the things that
I want to focus on here for a second
because
contrary to what you might think the
Suicide Squad is not allowed to do
whatever it is that they want to do
given the authority that Amanda Waller
has and how abrasive her personality is
she can really kind of inject herself in
any situation and she's really given a
lot of leeway but the other half of this
is that with the Suicide Squad acting as
this group that's supposed to be a
blackops group and supposed to engage in
missions where nobody can trace it back
to the US government there has to be
somebody monitoring what it is the
Suicide Squad does and so with regards
to Amanda Waller and the Amelia Harcourt
relationship Amanda Waller is
effectively a subordinate she's given a
lot of leeway in terms of what she does
with the Suicide Squad but Emilia
hardcourts there to make sure that if
Amanda Waller goes too far off the
reservation that she'll be removed from
her position and replaced with somebody
else and so again what is up happening
here is that by some unknown means at
least it's not explicitly explained on
the surface everybody begins to
effectively lose their mind so now it's
not just a sudden switch I mean it's to
a degree but the way that it's done
begins to make sense and the reason why
is because it starts with something
small it starts with the character of
HACC who again can basically transfer
physical objects by by way of a digital
stream and so the result is that she
initially starts seeing all these
different hallucinations all these
different images and of course words
like that people come together you know
bring the people back you know the world
has to come back all that kind of good
stuff just these weird little messages
and so on but the real way in which this
is transitioned it comes by way of rick
flagg
and the reason why is because of the
fact that General Zod is a very powerful
person he's basically Superman with a
couple of things that make them a little
bit stronger but also a couple things
that make him a little bit weaker and so
because of that if the Suicide Squad
were able to basically take hold of
General Zod and use him for their own
ends they would effectively have their
own version of Superman which presents
an interesting scenario for the team
itself just because of the fact that
there's a lot more that they could get
done remember when it comes to the
Suicide Squad on the whole with the
exception of like enchantress or El
Diablo there's really no one here that
has like any kind of insane enhanced
abilities I mean Killer Croc does to a
degree but it's really more like
durability and super strength more so
than anything else but with regards to
having General Zod on their side it
means they could literally send him in
as a one-man army contem just absolutely
wreck whoever it is they're supposed to
be going against and then recall him it
would almost make the rest of the
Suicide Squad obsolete now the other
half of this is that where Amanda Waller
views her duties as being someone that's
basically designed to protect the
rick flagg views himself as more of a
patriot than anything else and so in his
mind while General Zod would be a pretty
solid ally for the Suicide Squad
themselves at the end of the day his
argument is that the Suicide Squad is
designed to serve the benefit of the
u.s. not the benefit of the world and if
there were a being who was rolled over
to the Suicide Squad who would be a
danger to society as a whole that being
has to be removed in this case General
Zod now for the most part rick flagg
wouldn't really step into the role of
like publicly defying Amanda Waller and
there's a couple reasons for this the
first is because of the fact that what
Amanda Waller she just kill him on the
spot no questions asked if for no other
reason than to just make an example of
them but the other half of that is
because rick flagg despite the fact he
doesn't really like Amanda Waller too
much also shares a kind of respect to a
degree for what it is that she's trying
to achieve and so again that's one of
the reasons why he sought a part of this
team as part of a Suicide Squad and I
don't mean to say that there's
friendship they're never going to go out
and share a drink together I mean he
doesn't really like her but you don't
have to like someone to respect someone
so that's one of the interesting things
about this particular scenario now the
other half of this is that with
everything beginning to go awry but
people's personality is beginning to
switch and your good guys becoming bad
guys so on and so forth one is up
happening here it's katana actually
turns against the entirety of the
Suicide Squad now this is a pretty big
deal because remember this my katana not
having really special abilities unto
herself aside from all of our martial
arts training and sword fighting and so
on and so forth and the various souls
that are trapped within that sword she's
still a force to be reckoned with the
other half of this is that with General
Zod effectively waking up this comes by
way of the fact that with the various
you know governmental groups realizing
that Superman's biggest weakness is red
Sun radiation which will effectively
depower him it'll just kind of reduce
the solar radiation in his body and then
basically make him a normal person
General Zod is bombarded with the same
thing in order to keep him in stasis
while the experiment on and work on them
and see if they can try to make him a
member of The Suicide Squad but with the
red solar lights malfunctioning is
somebody screwing with them and emitting
solar rays well this basically just
begins the process of waking him up but
the cool thing about this is that Harley
Quinn also flips as well she basically
becomes a sane human being and that's
what makes this story so interesting is
not necessarily because of the fact that
Harley Quinn is sane but because of what
she can achieve as a sane person
remember Harley Quinn is not just so
girl who was just really enamored with
the Joker and then just fell in with a
bad crowd and then became the Joker's
sidekick for a little while the two of
them did whatever it is that they do
Harley Quinn is extremely intelligent
given her experience and you know
psychotherapy and you know our various
forms of Education and so on and so
forth she is a brilliant individual so
her ability to basically look at
everybody's individual actions how they
are now versus how they were before draw
her to one basic and almost infallible
conclusion that the black vault or
whatever is going on here has inverted
people's personalities but only insofar
that it's basically reduced them down to
their base instincts and so that's why
it is that katana is ripping everybody
to shreds because her base instinct is
to just destroy everything she comes
across to kill everybody that she can
now force the other half of this is
Harley Quinn you know overpowering who
she can where she can but this also hits
on the nature of Amanda Waller one of
the reasons why DC fans love Amanda
Waller so much is because she is
hardcore I mean it is it is absolutely
nuts how intense her character is and
she's like that in several different
ways I mean we as readers who go through
and read her stories we know she's not
someone to be messed with and we know
that if we read like a Batman story for
example and Amanda Waller shows up the
despite Bruce Wayne being Batman despite
his resources despite his vast
capabilities even he knows to give
Amanda Waller a pretty wide berth
because if she has her mind set on
something she will move heaven and earth
in order to make it happen and so if she
set her sights on Batman and wanted to
eliminate him in his entirety she would
you go to almost unlimited means to make
that happen
Batman would have to end run around her
either bring in the rest of the Justice
League or else go to the US government
or something along those lines to reel
Amanda Waller in he wouldn't be able to
bargain with her he wouldn't be able to
reason with her anything along those
lines but the other thing that this
shows us is that it's not a matter of
her just being cutthroat and being
cold-blooded and that kind of a thing
she's got to resolve like nothing
anyone's ever seen because while
everybody else in Belle Reve is losing
their minds and they're falling to their
base instincts and they're kind of going
awry Amanda Waller it's keeping it
together the best she can now the other
half of this is also rick flagg himself
and rick flies able to do this to a
degree but he does it by basically just
stabbing himself in the leg and what
this does is the equivalent of you know
breaking your finger in order to
distract the pain from something else
focusing on the pain in his leg
allows his mind to concentrate on one
particular thing as opposed to letting
it go awry because of this virus is
impacting everybody but switching back
over to uh to hack what we end up
finding out is that this virus that's
going around and impacting everyone
that's basically influencing the
blackball and kind of driving everybody
to go insane it's ultimately in Captain
Boomerang himself in the sense that he's
kind of emitting as a as a digital
aspect influencing the various minds of
people through the blackbolt and so on
and so forth it's kind of weird I'm not
even 100% sure that even I understand it
fully but basically it means that you
know Captain Boomerang is effectively
impacting these various individuals by
switching their minds and forcing them
back to their base instincts now it's
not something that he's doing because he
intends to he's doing it because he just
doesn't realize what it is it's
happening now of course at this point
with General Zod waking up because of
the fact that General Zod is so similar
to Superman
the only real ace in the hole that the
Suicide Squad have is June moon the
enchantress just because of the fact
that Kryptonians are basically weak to
magic is one of the caveats Superman has
and it's one of the ways to basically
invoke a defeat on his behalf without
using green kryptonite all the time so
because of this June moon basically
switches over to enchantress at the
behest of Harley Quinn and this
basically leads to the idea of you know
enchantress invoking her various magics
and so on and so forth in an effort to
try to defeat General Zod now in terms
of Captain Boomerang we get a little
more explanation here and essentially
what ended up happening is in the last
video when Captain Boomerang was totally
killed off what ended up taking place is
Captain Boomerang was basically
teleported as a digital essence so to
speak alongside the other members of the
Suicide Squad
when hack teleported them out and so
what this meant was a Captain Boomerang
basically just needed a physical body he
needed to be reconstituted but his
essence his soul or spirit or
what-have-you whatever you want to call
it we're still out there now with him
not having a physical body to transform
to you when he had arrived back in Belle
Reve prison he had basically just sort
of existed out there in this kind of
digital space so to speak the best way
to explain it really but was able to
essentially impact the black vault and
then use the abilities of the black
volta more or less trick everybody else
or impact everybody else's mind but
again it's not because of the fact that
he was doing it for a nefarious means it
was he was just trying to find a way
back he was trying to get himself back
to his normal human body now of course
following this it kind of leads to this
absolute mass pandemonium in the sense
of the guards are losing their minds
General Zod is trying to attack
everybody with Harley Quinn of course
being as sane as she ever was realizing
that the entire place is going awry and
the whole place is flooded with water an
electric shock of some measure well it
wouldn't necessarily be enough to kill
General Zod
it would definitely be enough to like
shock his body or impact him in a way it
would take some form of notice in turn
what this does is it allows HACC to
basically dive in and then almost try to
whisk him away or at the very least the
more or less knock him unconscious
I know suspected Lee what happens I mean
General Zod does it get whisked back
into the Phantom Zone again because the
goal of this story is to actually set
the stage for a General Zod to become a
member of The Suicide Squad so that's
why this is kind of cool is because what
this does is it leads into the
possibility that he will be brought in
and of course with him being brought in
and leading into them to the next couple
stories or so that sets the stage for
the whole action comics revenge
storyline when he's basically trying to
find a way to eliminate the suicide
squad or break away from them or
what-have-you while also trying to face
down Superman but again it's a small
little story here I mean it's for issues
long night but no not a great big thing
by any standard of measurement you know
but it is pretty cool in terms of how it
unfolds but uh but yeah guys we're gonna
go ahead and bring this video to an end
if you guys are new here to come this
explain to make sure you guys have a sub
button to become part of the robb pork
if you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and yeah I will catch
you all later please
[Music]